man of Madden is set almost entirely at
sea on an enormous abandoned boat
loosely based on the real-life ghost
ship mystery of the OSS Arang Madden man
of Madden is also the first part of
supermassive games proposed dark
pictures anthology a series of short
branching horror narrative experiences
in the vein of its tremendous 2015
surprise hit until dawn if you played
until dawn you'll know what to expect
but despite a smart online co-op mode
man of Madden's weak narrative
ultimately makes it a disappointing
first installment this is just McDonnell
standing in for a reviewer James O
Connor horrified he looks closer to see
the dead man's face in the dark closer
closer and he sees it's his own face and
then its eyes bulge out and screams
super twist nice nice one Squire man of
Madden's plot jumps between five
different playable characters who were
all experiencing the same event you'll
determine their ultimate fates by making
decisions for them as well as responding
to QuickTime events there are reportedly
69 different potential deaths you can
experience but it's also entirely
possible that your whole crew will
survive alternatively they might all die
in conversations and at pivotal points
in the plot you'll often be given three
options one of which is always to say or
do nothing so focused is Man of madden
on its story there are no puzzles to
solve all combat systems to master
outside of these choices just lots of
exploring and QuickTime events however
the game is plagued by a big central
problem a fundamentally weak plot the
story isn't engaging since the player is
given little reason to care about the
characters and the horror tropes being
explored mostly feel hackneyed and
uncreated after a brief prologue scene
set in the 40s you spend man of madhan's
roughly 4 hour runtime in the present
day the story opens with the crew
planning a dive to a previously
untouched sunken fighter plane from
world war ii which ultimately leads to a
series of events that sees them
crapped on the Madonn a seemingly
haunted abandoned ship held captive by a
pirate gang who were convinced that the
ship which is riddled with dead bodies
contains treasure naturally things start
going bump in the night and the gang
finds themselves dealing with various
goals and terrors there are plot holes
and character inconsistencies throughout
some minor some more blatant it's easy
to forgive the questionable presence of
rats all over the boat still knowing on
hunks of meat that have been on the ship
since the 40s but it's less easy to
excuse how PLAs day the characters act
about the horrifying situations they
find themselves in the dialog is
generally not very good either at times
it successfully recreates the feeling of
watching a fun but silly teen slasher
but it can also be annoying when the
five central characters interactions
sounds stilted and unrealistic yeah man
this whole rust buckets one tetanus shot
from the bottom of the ocean we already
tried to escape didn't exactly work out
without spoiling anything the story
explains a little too much about what's
happening on the Madonn in a way that
makes repeated playthroughs much less
satisfying there's also an over-reliance
on jump scares which cheapens the horror
experience on the plus side it looks
tremendous the character models can be a
bit waxy but the ship is extremely
detailed and creepy and the game
effectively communicates how unpleasant
the act of exploring a creaky rust
bucket full of dark corners and rotting
corpses must be
you hear that if by that you mean that
terrifying sound then no I didn't write
you know you did was it something moving
something moving would make that sound
sure the trade-off at least on a bass
ps4 is that the animations frequently
stutter breaking the mood as frames slip
away there are pacing issues too
especially with the extremely slow
opening section that weighs down repeat
playthroughs multiplayer is man of
madhan's big addition to the formula
laid out by until dawn there are two
forms of co-op shared story in which two
players tackle the game together online
and movie night where up to 5 players
can play together offline playing
through the chapters of whichever
characters they are assigned at the
start playing together on the couch is
perhaps meant to evoke that don't go in
there feeling of watching a fun horror
movie with friends but death is more
often down to a failed QuickTime event
rather than a dialogue choice you made
or because you decided to investigate
something spooky in fact right near the
end a mistimed button press can be the
difference between everyone surviving
and everybody dying being responsible
for that in front of your friends is
more embarrassing than it is funny
however so many of the game's issues
feel like much less of a problem when
you jump into the smart and innovative
online mode shed story sees you both
playing at the same time taking control
of different characters as the scenes
play out simultaneously you'll both
eventually get a turn with every
character if they live long enough and
often your pods will diverge in
single-player you'll still see both
scenes but one will be greatly truncated
in online co-op some of these scenes are
expanded or you might occasionally see
parts of the story or make choices that
cannot be accessed in single-player
working together in online co-op and
choosing to reveal what just happened
and when to let the other person try and
figure out what we've done in our scenes
was a delight no matter how much or how
little you choose to share though shared
story is absolutely the right way to
play the game being able to see how your
friend is trying to direct a scene and
deciding whether to help or hinder them
in that is excellent man of Madden is
still telling a weak story though as
much as shared story plasters over this
with its excellent take on co-op as a
show of the potential for the dark
picture's anthology man of Madden is
largely a success but as
first episode it leaves plenty to be
desired
[Music]